SPEAKER: So this
event is sort of
to highlight some of the work
being done around LGBT youth
work by an organization
called Lambda Legal.
Many of you guys may be
familiar with Lambda already.
They've been around since
1973 with the primary goal
of fighting for full
equality for LGBT people
and those living with HIV,
through primarily impact
litigation and then also
education and policy work.
So they're based in New York.
They have presence in a
few other cities in the US.
And they're in the process
of opening an office in DC
right now.
Given the kind of new
political climate,
there's a lot of work to be
done there, as you guys know.
So that process is ongoing.
And one note that
was pointed out to me
is that Lambda has won a
lot of their big victories
during hostile administrations.
It can be done.
And will continue to
be done, as judiciary
is a really important path
for us to make progress.
So since we're talking
about LGBT youth today,
I'd like to introduce you to
Currey Cook, who is actually
the Director of the Youth
in Out-of-Home Care Project.
He's also a staff
council at Lambda,
which means he's a lawyer.
And he has a lot of experience
working with LGBT youth.
So before this,
he was co-director
of the Bronx office
of the Children's Law
Center in New York.
He's also been a consultant to
the National Juvenile Defenders
Center in Washington.
He worked in Burundi
on an initiative
to assist with reintegration
of former child soldiers
into society.
And before that, he spent
12 years in New York
as an attorney for children
in foster care and juvenile
justice.
So he has a lot of
experience in this field.
There's no one better to
speak to us about this.
Mr. Currey Cook.
[APPLAUSE]
CURREY COOK: Hi everyone.
So I'm going to talk to
you just for a little bit
to give you kind of an
overview of the landscape,
particularly around young
people who are in what we
call youth in out-of-home care.
So what we mean by that
term is young people
that are in the
foster care system,
in the juvenile justice
system, and youth that
are experiencing homelessness.
And also a little bit about
LGBTQ+ young people that are
undocumented, particularly
in our current climate.
Obviously that's a big
concern with what's
going on around immigration
and refugees in our country.
So I'm going to talk
for a little bit.
But then I'm going
to turn it over
to the really important
people for you to hear from,
which are three of my awesome
clients who are joining us.
And one of them is Soul, who's
here, who now lives in Fremont.
But I met him when
he was in the Bronx.
And then Savannah, who is
in Pittsburgh, living there
in foster care right now.
And then Lydia,
who lives in Texas,
and was in long-term
juvenile justice facilities
for two years and experienced
a lot of discrimination
and mistreatment
while locked up there.
So I think it will be really
great for me to hear directly
from them about
their experiences
as gay and trans
young people who
are involved in these systems.
I'm also going to talk just
a little bit about school.
Obviously there's been a lot in
the news about trans students
in school and a Trump
administration reversal
of guidance to protect
trans students in school,
and a recent decision
by the Supreme Court
to kick a case back down.
G.G., which you may
have heard about.
Gavin Grimm's case.
So I'll also talk about
that, and just some
of the broader work that's going
on, because it's all related,
of course, right?
So first I'll just kind
of give you a little bit
of an overview of all this.
And then we'll get into
the good conversation.
So, obviously, when we're
talking about identity
for folks, it encompasses all
kinds of things for all of us,
right?
And our gender identity,
the sex that we
are assigned at birth, our
sexual orientation, all
of those are components
of who we are as a whole.
Goes without saying, kind of.
But I mention it here
because particularly
in the systems that
we're talking about,
overwhelmingly it's
young people of color
that are represented in these
out-of-home care systems,
like foster care and
juvenile justice,
because of social
justice issues,
institutional racism,
all kinds of things
that drive young people of color
into those systems at higher
rates, right?
So when we're talking
about the young people
that I'm going to be going over
and talking about their rights
today, really we're
talking about queer trans
youth of color.
That's who we're
talking about, OK?
So that's why I wanted to put
this on, a slide up, so you
can think about kind
of people holistically,
even though we're going
to be specifically talking
about sexual orientation and
gender identity, sex, and all
that today.
So there's not nearly enough
data about how LGBTQ+ young
people are doing in these
systems because it's really
difficult, for
important reasons,
not to be doing research on
children and particularly
children that are
in custody, right?
But we do know some things, OK?
So part of this data I've
kind of summarized here
in this chart, which is
kind of this vicious cycle
that a lot of
LGBTQ young people,
particularly young people of
color, get into, all right?
And that is if you've
been rejected from home
because of who you are-- so your
parents have literally kicked
you out, which happens to way
too many LGBTQ+ young people,
right--
then you can go directly to
experiencing homelessness.
Or you might be picked up by
the foster care system, placed
into foster care.
If you're not treated
well in foster care
and are running away
from a foster home that
isn't supportive
of you, then you
could go from there
to homelessness.
Or if you have a conflict
with your foster parent
because they don't
like who you are
or the way you present, and
you get into a fight in school
or at home, and then
get an assault charge,
then you can go over to the
juvenile justice system.
Or if you're in a school
and you're being bullied--
and Lydia will talk a
little bit about this,
right-- then you can
go straight from school
into the juvenile
justice system.
How many of you have
seen "Moonlight?"
All righty.
Right?
There's a really, like, just--
scene there that really
hits home, right,
of Chiron being
picked on in school,
and then he gets
arrested and hauled off
because he's fighting
back for being picked on.
So that's kind of what
we're talking about here.
And I have additional
factors on there
to think about other aspects
of identity and who you are,
particularly thinking about
if you're undocumented.
And all of this is kind
of happening, right?
Like the additional layers of
challenges that you may face.
And, unfortunately,
this cycle happens
for a lot of young people.
But for LGBTQ+ youth, and
particularly those of color,
this is, like, on steroids.
So you're going from
one system to the other,
you are multi systemic
involved, and also
if you're in foster care and
you haven't been affirmed there,
then that can lead to sort
of all of these other things,
and then sort of
back in again, right?
So just important to think about
the different layers of system
involvement, kind of the reasons
why and that this cycle happens
at elevated rates for
LGBTQ+ young people.
OK.
So people always want to
know what the numbers are.
Like, what are we talking about?
That, again, as I
said earlier, is
challenging because we don't
necessarily have enough data.
But what we do have is a study
out of Los Angeles County that
basically found that out of
this 700+ young people they
surveyed, 19.1%
identified as LGBTQ.
So that's over double, probably,
than our estimates of LGBTQ+
people in the
general population.
And then if you look at this one
circle with transgender youth,
the survey came out with 5.6%
of the young people surveyed
identifying as trans, which,
if our estimates are maybe
1% to 2% of people in
general identifying as trans,
that's enormous
over-representation.
So kind of going back
to our, like, why
are those numbers so high?
So much of it is fueled
by family rejection.
So, kids getting kicked out
and ending up in these systems,
even though they may end up
for other reasons, that's
largely what's fueling it.
In the juvenile justice system,
the numbers are the same.
20%.
I mean, one study in
Northern California
recently, about 30% of girls
who are in the juvenile justice
system in California
identified somewhere
along the LGBTQ spectrum.
So we're talking about a way
over-representation, which
is why Lambda has this youth in
out-of-home care project that I
focus on, which is
because there's so
many young people
in these systems
and we know that they have
really bad experiences there,
many of them, OK?
So this also leads to this
criminalization factor
I was talking about when
I alluded to "Moonlight."
But there are all kinds
of other pipelines.
How many of you heard of the
school-to-prison pipeline?
Heard that term before?
That's one that justifiably
gets a lot of attention
and conversation.
But there are other pipelines.
So I mentioned the foster
care prison pipeline.
So conflict in a group
home, if you're placed there
with other peers who
aren't accepting of you
or staff who aren't
accepting of you,
can lead to an assault
charge that gets you in jail.
Youth who are
experiencing homelessness
who may be engaging in what some
people call survival crimes.
So, for example, you
are engaging in sex work
because you have to pay
for a place to sleep.
Or you're experiencing
homelessness, don't have a job,
and you need to access
public transportation.
I live in New York.
So you jump the
subway turnstile,
and then you get picked up,
and then you get a warrant,
and then you don't have money to
pay the warrant, and that sort
of cycle starts, right?
And then the bottom one
we have is walking while.
So you may have heard people
talk about being picked up
and walking while black or
driving while black, right?
So for, say, trans
women of color
are often profiled as engaging
in sex work or prostitution
or just picked up walking
down the street, right?
Because of profiling by police.
So, for example, if you are an
African-American transgender
woman of color in the
foster care system living
in Baton Rouge, Louisiana, for
example, one of my clients,
you could have all of
these things happening
to you simultaneously or in
different aspects of your life.
So just thinking
about all the factors
that kind of drive young people
into these systems at higher
numbers.
The foster care
system is one that's
kind of surprising
for folks that ends up
having youth experiencing
homelessness because you think,
well, isn't that the point
of being in foster care
is that you have
a place to live?
And you have someone who will
adopt you or care for you?
But, unfortunately, in
the foster care system,
if you don't have people
working to help you get back
with your family, to help them
understand you and accept you,
then you can end up
in a foster home.
If the foster home doesn't
accept you for who you are--
and we'll hear
from Savannah talk
a little bit about
that in a minute--
then you can end up in a
shelter or a group home.
If that's not
supportive, then you
can take off, because you
don't feel safe there.
And then you can end up homeless
and with no adult connected
to you outside the system.
So all of this stuff leads to
this really shocking figure,
which is 40%.
And that is estimates
of youth who
are experiencing
homelessness that
identify in the LGBTQ spectrum,
which again, if we think
about maybe 7% to
10% being the numbers
in the general
population, that's
just crazy over-representation
for all of these factors
I talked about.
And then for young people
that are in these systems,
once they're in, all
kinds of problems
can happen and do happen.
So one is just not feeling
safe to say who you are.
So not being able
to come out or talk
about your sexual orientation
or identity or express yourself
freely leads to
isolation, which causes
a lot of bad
outcomes, depression,
suicidal ideation,
those sorts of things.
Being victimized.
So Lydia is going to talk a
little bit about her experience
in the juvenile justice
facility and being
a victim of assault in
there because of who she is.
Differential treatment.
So, say, straight kids
are allowed to date
and have friends over, have sort
of normal relationships, right,
but a foster parent may
not allow a young person
to have a same-sex friend over
that they're attracted to,
or things like that.
So different rules applying.
And then these
disclosure dilemmas
are confidentiality violations.
So if you do say
who you are, lots
of things you have
to navigate around,
whether it's safe to do that,
how that's going to play,
are you going to be
rejected once you come out.
Confidentiality.
So if you do say who
you are, do people
gossip about that
to somebody else?
Are you outed to other
people without you knowing?
And then I mentioned
earlier, kind of lack
of family-centered services.
So the foster care
system is supposed
to help you get safely back
to your parents if you can.
But if no one's actually
working with your parents
on accepting you
for who you are,
then you're already cycling
further into the system,
like we talked about.
And then, finally,
and a big one,
is the lack of cultural
competency in serving
LGBT youth in these systems.
So a big example is if you're
a transgender young person
and you're referred to a
doctor or medical provider who
knows nothing about working
with trans young people,
then you're not going to
get accurate information
about whether you may be able
to begin hormone therapy,
if you're a younger
person, if you're eligible
or a good candidate for
puberty blockers, right?
You're not getting
accurate information.
For some of my gay
clients in foster care,
no one has ever mentioned
to them about PrEP,
or the possibility
of being on PrEP,
so you're really kind of having
to navigate all of these things
within the context
of health care.
And so you're not
actually getting
your needs met, or accurate
information when you're there.
So, real quickly, I'll
talk just a little bit
about the more boring parts.
Since I'm a lawyer, I feel
obligated to talk about this,
which is the law
and policies that
protects young people
in these systems, right?
So you have constitutional
rights if you're in care.
You have the right
to be treated fairly.
So, to equal protection.
You also have the right to due
process, which means safety.
Your physical and
emotional safety.
So if the state has taken
you away from your parents
and placed you out
of home, then they
have an obligation to
ensure that you're safe.
So every kid in care
has these rights.
Additionally, there
are federal statutes
that provide protection
for discrimination.
So on the juvenile justice
side, the Juvenile Justice
and Delinquency Prevention
Act prohibits discrimination
based on sex.
So we'll talk a little bit
about sex-based discrimination.
But more and more
courts are saying,
no, sex as a protected class
includes sex stereotyping.
So assuming that men
should be dating women
and marrying women, right?
Or that you should be conforming
to some sort of expectations
for the sex that you were
assigned at birth and the way
you present yourself.
And also gender identity, right?
Clearly, obviously
connected with sex, right?
So there may be
protections there.
Regulations.
At the end of the
Obama administration,
a couple of major
regulations came out
that provide
explicit protection.
So they say you may
not discriminate
based on sexual orientation,
gender identity,
and gender expression
for youth that
are being served by
homeless shelters that
receive federal funding.
So that is fantastic, right?
But those are some
of the things that
are at risk with this
current administration
and current Congress.
So those are regulations that
they may pull back completely,
cut out through the
Congressional Review Act,
or try to go through
the regulatory process
to get rid of those.
On the foster care
side, a big one
came out that said if you
receive federal funding
from Health and
Human Services, then
you can't discriminate based on
sexual orientation and gender
identities.
That includes child
welfare agencies, right?
And under the Obama
administration,
a lot of the federal agencies
that look at these things
did a lot of great
work around LGBTQ.
So all that stuff is
absolutely at risk
now and what we have
to be vigilant about.
So from state to state, each
state systems in these areas
may have explicit protections.
So probably to the
surprise of no one,
the top two states in
terms of adding protection
for kids in these areas are
New York and California.
The bottom two, which have no
explicit protection, including
sexual orientation, gender
identity, or expression,
or even sex in their laws
applicable to these systems
are Alaska and North
Carolina, which as we know,
North Carolina is already not
doing good things with HB2
in their bill, which
we are litigating
with the ACLU against them.
Also some public accommodation
laws and human rights laws
may protect kids.
So I want to--
I'll show you a quick map
of this and then I'll close.
But I do want to
emphasize particularly
that transgender youth who
are involved in these systems
really bear the brunt of
a ton of discrimination
around who they are, from the
basics of not respecting name
and pronouns to not
getting qualified care.
Like I said, being
placed, if you are a girl,
being placed in a
boy's group home
because they interpret
the requirement
to place youth of different
genders in different facilities
as gender assigned at birth
rather than who you really are.
So because all of these
systems are so sex-segregated,
trans youth, or youth who
don't conform with expectations
of their gender
assigned at birth,
really just get
all kinds of stuff.
And Savannah is going to talk
a little bit about that and how
she's in an affirming
program now.
So, real quick, I
will just show you,
to kind of give you an idea.
So this is kind of a map--
is a map, actually--
of the United States
and showing what states
have no protection.
So you can see the red states--
so this is in the
child welfare system--
have no explicit
protections that
include sexual orientation,
gender identity, or expression.
Why is that important?
Because if you're
working in these systems,
if you're a
professional, say you're
a staff at a group home
for kids in foster care,
and your training
says you may not
discriminate
against young people
because our law or policy
says you can't, then you
can get the message.
And it's clear.
If not, and somebody
says, you shouldn't
be doing that, then you
could say, well, why?
Where does it say that?
Right?
Nobody told me.
Like, the law doesn't
say that, right?
So it just allows for people's
essential personal biases--
beliefs-- to creep in.
So I do a lot of work
around the country
of trying to make
sure that states
do have explicit
protection and that they
do training to make
sure that people working
with young people
in these systems
understand that they
must treat young people--
must affirm their identity,
must treat them well,
must make sure that they don't--
they must not treat
them differently,
right, than non-LGBTQ
kids in their care.
So that's the child
welfare system.
And then you can see the
juvenile justice system.
Right.
If I can scroll down
just a little bit here.
Yeah.
You get the idea.
So we have a report
coming out soon
with children's rights and the
Center for the Study of Social
Policy that summarizes
all of this law, talks
about the protections
in the state,
and also and really
importantly features providers
in the juvenile justice world--
runaway and homeless youth
shelters, foster care--
that actually are affirming
transgender youth.
So one of my clients
is now and Kate--
and Savannah, too,
that you'll hear from--
are now on in
girls' programming.
So as a transgender girl,
the state foster care agency
has placed them in a girls'
group home, as they should,
right?
So we're highlighting
people that
are doing the right thing
as we know a lot of schools
are, too, in affirming
young people.
And also having six
young people, who
are trans or
gender-nonconforming,
who are describing their
positive experiences,
because we hear so many
horror stories because a lot
of bad stuff is happening.
But also really
important to know
that there are a lot of
people doing the right thing.
And a lot of young people
that are benefiting from that.
And so I will use
that as my segue over
into hearing from some of them.
So, Soul, you want
to come up first?
So this is Savannah,
who lives in Pittsburgh.
And Lydia, you
want to say hello?
LYDIA: Hello.
CURREY COOK: And this is Lydia,
who lives in San Antonio.
So I was talking a little
bit about focusing kind
of on youth in foster
care, juvenile justice,
runaway and homeless
youth systems.
But Soul, we actually
met because Soul
came to our attention
when we reached out
to the LGBT center
in New York City
and were asking them about
whether they were seeing
undocumented LGBTQ
young people coming in
and sort of what they
were doing about that.
Like how were they
accessing legal help
for those young people.
So maybe we'll start with Soul,
if you don't mind telling folks
a little bit about
where you're from
and how you ended up in the US?
SOUL: Yeah, sure.
Basically, my name is Soul.
And I'm from West Africa.
I moved out here in 2014.
So, basically, I'm a student.
And I'm part of LGBT people
[INAUDIBLE] community.
So when I was in Africa, as
you know, like, in Africa,
LGBT people are--
they don't have no
rights, you know?
They don't have the right.
And it's a little bit hard
for us, for LGBT community,
to defend themself over there,
and at the same time to--
there is no right, you know?
And so, basically, I had
an issue with my family.
And the only way I find
[INAUDIBLE] to move here
to the United States.
And, basically, I didn't
go like a [INAUDIBLE].
Like I didn't tell
myself, I'm going
to come here to the United
States because of the problem
I have with my family.
But I just told
myself, I'm just going
to move out here to basically to
pursue my education and stuff.
And I was lucky to have some
friends going to university
when I sent my paper over
there, and they just accepted me
as an international student.
And then moved out there.
So, basically,
when I come here--
and I didn't tell
my family why I'm
going to move here
in the United States.
I didn't tell them
because I want
to stay here because I'm
going to be safe here
in the United States.
But I just told them I'm
going to study there.
And when I got here I stopped
my education at the same time
I lost any contact
with my family.
So, basically, that's
how I just stay here.
And after that, things went
a little bit difficult for me
when I was in San Francisco.
And then I moved in New
York City two months after.
Then one month after that, I
heard about LGBT community.
Because in Africa, we
don't have LGBT community.
The thing is, I didn't
really know why we have
LGBT community here in Africa--
here in America.
You know?
I never heard about it.
CURREY COOK: You
mean the center?
The LGBT Center.
SOUL: The LBGT Center.
Sorry.
The LBGT Center.
So, basically, I
went there to see.
I'm just going to go
see if I kind of like--
I'm just going to go there
and know about it, you know,
because I never heard
that before, you know?
And when I went there, I really
see amazing people over there.
And the people,
they were very cool.
You know, like, they helped me.
And they wanted to know about
my story, to know about--
to know why I decide
to come here, you know?
And at the beginning, it
was a little bit difficult.
It wasn't easy for me.
Because I couldn't
like share my story.
I couldn't tell
exactly what happened
to me to people like this.
No, I cannot like, just--
I don't know you.
I cannot just come and tell you
exactly what happened to me,
you know?
But after that, like,
with time and stuff,
I just share my story.
And right now I'm happy to do
that because they helped me.
And at the same time, I meet
with Currey and Currey helped
me to be a resident here.
Yeah.
And, yeah.
That's how I can work here,
I can go to school, and yeah.
That's basically
how I end up here.
CURREY COOK: Do you
want to tell them
a little bit about how
you were able to get
your legal residency?
SOUL: So, basically, as I said,
I was international student
before.
And international student here,
you cannot work, you cannot--
you don't have a
social security,
you don't have
working permit stuff.
So, basically, when I
started working with Currey,
he sent my paperwork
to Immigration, right?
And before that, I was underage.
I was 20.
And then, so basically, I was
supposed to have a [INAUDIBLE].
CURREY COOK: Yeah.
It's called-- so
there's a provision
in federal immigration law
called Special Immigrant
Juvenile Status.
So what it says is if you
have been abused, neglected,
or abandoned by one or both of
your parents, you're under 21,
you're unmarried, and it's
not in your best interest
to go back to your
home country, then
you can apply to
have a green card.
And because of what happened
with Soul's dad, when Soul came
out to his dad when he
was here, basically,
he just completely cut him off.
He was left here with nowhere
to go, no one to stay with.
And then you want to tell them
how you ended up in the Bronx?
SOUL: When I was
in San Francisco
and I had this issue
with my family,
I did not have anywhere to go.
And how I'm going
to pay my rent,
how I'm going to pay school
and stuff, that was my problem.
And then I had one
friend in New York City.
And when I asked him, like,
when I shared my story with him
and I really tell
him like, right now
I really need help
and stuff, and yeah.
Him and his brothers,
they just told
me to come to New York City.
And that's how I ended
up in New York City.
And I [INAUDIBLE], like, if
they weren't here for me,
I don't know how I'm
going to be like.
I don't know where
I'm going to go.
Maybe I'm going to
be homeless maybe.
You know?
And that's how I went
to New York City.
And at the same time, as I
said, we went [INAUDIBLE] when
I went to the Bronx
court for my paperwork,
one of my friend's
brother here, he
accept to become my
guardian, you know?
And that's how I
ended up to have
my legal permanent residency.
Yeah.
CURREY COOK: Yeah.
So one of the pieces of Special
Immigrant Juvenile Status
is you have to be under the
jurisdiction of a family
or juvenile court.
That can be through foster care,
maybe because you're involved
in a juvenile justice case.
But it can also be because
someone is actually
being your legal guardian.
So Soul was staying with
this friend and their brother
and they were actually
being his guardian.
But they didn't have legal
paperwork that said that.
So we went to court and had New
York City Family Court declare
his friend his legal
guardian, and they
were able to get these
findings that I mentioned
and apply for
immigration status.
And important for you
to know, while there's
been a lot of attention
on Trump's travel ban
and focus on refugees
from certain places,
right, that there's
also rumblings
that Congress may move to
take away Special Immigrant
Juvenile Status entirely.
So just be aware.
You may be getting alerts from
us if that happens, right?
So something that
is also in the works
and all this kind
of bad stuff that's
happening on the
immigration front.
Maybe we can hear now from
Lydia, since you're up.
Do you want to tell
us just a little bit--
I mentioned you'd ended up in
the juvenile justice system.
Do you want to just
kind of tell folks
a little bit about how you
ended up there and a little bit
about what your experiences
were like while you
were in the facilities?
LYDIA: Yeah.
Well, I pretty much just
ended up in there from--
when I was in school, I was
getting picked on like really,
really bad.
At the time, I
wasn't really open.
But if someone asked, I
would, you know, tell him.
Eventually, everybody ended
up knowing in the school.
It got to a point to where at
the start of my eighth grade
year, just, it got horrible.
Like, I would get in fights
at school protecting myself.
I would go home just
like everything's OK.
Normally, everything
wasn't, with what
was going on at school.
And at one point it was like--
I guess people was [? study ?]
coming towards me, threatening
me, and someone had pushed
me down the stairs at school
one time.
I had got thrown up
against the lockers.
And people was-- it was
all just stuff like that.
And went into my
ninth grade year.
It got way worse.
People was-- it just
got to the point
to where I had tried to
kill myself at one point.
And, like, the best things
in the school that helped me
stay calm, I'll say
calm, or, you know,
helped me vent in different
ways, which was the theater
arts and JROTC, it's
like a little [INAUDIBLE]
like Army [INAUDIBLE] for
preparation things at school.
They had kicked me
out of it because I
had went to the detention center
because I had fought someone
at home.
And they had kicked
me out of it at school
because they said they
it's a bad look on them.
And eventually I
had ended up getting
put in a residential treatment
center here in San Antonio.
And they was-- sorry.
They had youth come
after me sometimes, I
guess I would say it like that.
They had youth come
after me sometimes, you
know, just to fight me.
Because I was honest, I guess.
I was honest.
I spoke my mind.
I really didn't hold
back on much to say.
And if someone heard what I
said, they would turn it to,
oh, I was trying
to flirt with them,
or I was trying to hit
on them, something.
And people have
ended up fighting me
so much, back to back to back,
that I just gave up, I guess?
And I just started
fighting everyone back.
Then, a little bit
after that, they
had kicked me out of that
place and put me back
in the detention center.
And I waited a few months.
They put me in the Texas
Juvenile Justice Department,
TJJD for short.
In there, I have to say,
with the people jumping me
and molesting me
because of who I am,
it made it harder for me to
be able to do my treatment.
With the staffs that [INAUDIBLE]
you different type of things.
Contraband.
They would give them food.
They would give them
actual money sometimes.
They would give
them razorblades,
all types of stuff, to
get them to fight me.
And sometimes it would be
staff that would actually
try to fight me, too.
It was really difficult
for me in there.
I ended up in the
hospital several times
because of the people
fighting me in general.
Staff, my case manager,
had put in the database,
I guess it's called.
I don't really remember
what it's called.
But she had put in
there that I should
start acting more
masculine, and if I
was were to act
more boyish or act
straight I wouldn't
get beat up so much
if I act, quote unquote,
"like a little girl."
It made things really
difficult for me in general
to just progress in the program.
And then the halfway
house they had sent me to,
before I had found out anything
of me going to a halfway house,
they said that, oh,
you're going to go
to a all-boys halfway house.
And I was like, what is this?
With that, they had promised
me all these different things.
But when I got there, it
was the total opposite.
Like they promised me that
I would have my own room.
I wouldn't be roomed with any
other youth or any other boys.
I would be able to dress
and act freely, as I choose.
And, also, they said
that I would be able--
if I was were to
go on a home pass,
I could come back with hair
extensions or my nails done,
or makeup, or whatever.
And even the money
I would have made
while I was in
the halfway house,
they said that I would be
able to spend it on things
that I choose.
Now, when I got there,
they changed all of that.
Like, it was just, no.
You can't do this.
You can't do that.
I had got threatened
by a youth there.
He had said that he was
going to call his sister
and have her come and shoot
me because of pretty much
how I present myself.
And just through that
whole time it was just--
it was just hard to be
able to have them say, you
can be yourself but
you can't be yourself
if this is what you
are trying to be.
They were contradicting
themselves, pretty much.
And I was like,
how are you going
to say that I can be myself,
I can dress how I want,
and all this other
stuff, but then you
scratch out the part for
homosexuals or anyone
in the LGBTQ community.
And you say they
can't be themselves,
but the other ones can.
[INAUDIBLE]
CURREY COOK: Let me
just pause right there
and just tell everyone a
little bit of background.
So Lydia has had an amazing,
supportive mom throughout.
And during her year and a
half time in these facilities,
her mom was calling and
complaining about her treatment
and eventually
called our help desk,
which is how we got
connected with Lydia
and gathered all records, which
documented all the things she
was saying, being
repeatedly assaulted,
not being protected,
going to the hospital
because kids were beating
her up because of how she was
expressing herself, not
acknowledging that at the time,
Lydia was basically expressing,
I identify as female.
I want to be treated as female.
But being absolutely
shut down in all of that.
And eventually, when
we wrote a big letter
and had a big meeting,
and then suddenly she
was able to get out even
though she hadn't met
her levels in two years, right?
But even then they
wanted to place
Lydia at this halfway house
for boys, which we opposed.
But when she got there, she
said to the superintendent,
you know, they told me I'd
be able to express myself.
And the superintendent
said, well no,
because the only
reason you'd be doing
that is to try to seduce
the other boys in the room.
I mean, just kind of
just ridiculous stuff.
And Texas actually has sexual
orientation and gender identity
as protected classes
in their policy.
But obviously that
wasn't translating
into the staff and work.
So going back to
what I mentioned
earlier about training
being critical, right?
This is a good example of staff
doing this stuff that's clearly
not good for young people.
And, you know, and
Lydia actively getting
hurt, right, as a part of it.
So the good news
is that Lydia was
able to get out of the halfway
house soon, back with her mom,
had a really affirming and
amazing parole officer,
is off parole, working
now, and doing awesome.
So that's good news.
So why don't we turn
and hear from Savannah.
You ready?
Savannah?
So why don't you tell
folks a little bit about--
you're in foster
care now, why don't
you tell them a little
about where you are now,
and how that is, and then
a little bit about how
you got into care?
SAVANNAH: All right.
First I think we should give
Lydia and Soul some applause.
[APPLAUSE]
I was very moved by
both of your stories.
So thank you for sharing them.
I am currently living
in what's called
a supervised
independent living home.
And it's a girls' home.
And all of the other youth
here have been very affirming.
And the staff has definitely
been very affirming.
And it's a good place.
I basically have my own
efficiency apartment.
And it's basically
teaching us to-- it's kind
of like a halfway house from
leaving foster care going
into the real world, you
know, and becoming an adult.
And I think it's a
very good place for me.
As far as how I got here, I was
living with my parents for--
I lived with them for 16 years.
And I was always very,
very close with my mom.
And I had a really
good childhood.
I am glad to say that I
have very good memories
from my childhood.
And my mom always says
I was a wonderful child,
a wonderful toddler
and child, and then
once I got to my
teenage years, that's
when things kind of started
to get a little bit shaky.
I was going through
a lot of depression.
And it was not entirely
because, but it
had a lot to do
with, the fact that I
felt as though I could not
come out as trans because I
knew around 14 or 15.
And the thing is,
I couldn't come out
because my parents-- my dad
is a pastor at our church.
And very, you know, I don't
want to say anti-LGBT,
but not affirming
most definitely.
And so eventually
it just kind of--
I just kind of blew up one day.
And I actually had
come out to my parents
through a suicide note.
So I was [INAUDIBLE] suicide.
And then we went to counseling.
And things started
to get better.
But they still
weren't affirming.
They knew, which was better
than before, I suppose, but they
weren't affirming.
So it wasn't a whole lot better.
And then one time--
yeah.
It was soon after my
16th birthday, I think.
I had ended up in a psych ward
because of suicidal ideations
because I was still
wasn't allowed to come out
to anyone else, really.
And it's not--
I guess it's not the
hardest thing in the world,
but it's not easy to have
to hide all the time.
And my first foster home
that I was placed in--
oh yeah, well, I
couldn't go back home.
So I had to be placed
in foster care.
So the first foster home
that I was placed in
was definitely not affirming.
And the agency wasn't affirming.
And it was-- once
again, I was closeted.
And I had to just go
to school as a boy
and live my life as
a boy and, you know--
first of all, it
wasn't pleasant.
But second, it was
entirely counterproductive.
The entire reason
that I was placed
in care in the first
place was because
of problems at home relating
to my gender identity
not being affirmed.
So I was removed from that
situation with my parents
and put into an
identical situation.
The only thing that's changed
is where I am and who I'm with.
The situation
itself is the same.
So it just wasn't--
I don't think it
was a logical move.
And then there
were other problems
at that home entirely unrelated
to my gender identity.
And, ultimately, I was
removed from that home
for those reasons.
And it didn't have anything
to do with my gender identity.
But then I was
placed in a new home.
They also weren't affirming.
But I was allowed
to be out at school.
I was allowed to express myself
through how I present myself,
how I dress, my name and
pronouns, how I introduce
myself to people, et cetera.
CURREY COOK: And
Savannah, so you
were at school in a pretty rural
area in Pennsylvania, right?
SAVANNAH: Oh, yes.
Yeah.
All three of these
placements my ho--
I'm sorry?
CURREY COOK: No, that's OK.
Go ahead.
SAVANNAH: All three of
my placements-- my home,
my first foster home, and
then this second foster home--
they were all very rural areas.
And it's not that the people
at school weren't accepting.
I think they just didn't know
how to react to it, I guess.
I'm not sure.
They had never-- transgender
people aren't exactly plentiful
in schools such as that.
And not that there was any
stigma against people like me.
They just didn't know anything
about transgender people
or the community.
And they-- I feel like
I made a lot of people
feel awkward just
by being there.
It wasn't--
CURREY COOK: I'm sorry.
I remember you
telling me that it
didn't seem like the people
running the foster care
agencies and from the
county knew anything
about working with
transgender youth
or had ever had any training
SAVANNAH: Oh yeah,
they didn't either, no.
CURREY COOK: And can you
tell everyone a little bit--
I know you had a particular
issue around clothing when
you wanted to get clothing.
Do you want to tell us--
SAVANNAH: Yeah.
So, yes.
The agency was
very non-affirming.
And I can deal with
misgendering and calling me
by the wrong name.
I mean, people are going
to do that all the time.
And my parents do that.
And I still love them to death.
But, you know, Currey
talked in a slideshow
about not discriminating
based on gender.
Like not even just
gender identity.
Just on your biological sex.
I mean, they would--
OK, so they provide each child
a clothing allotment of--
but it was some monthly
clothing allotment
so we can go out and buy
clothing for ourselves to wear.
And so it had to be--
in the guidelines, it said
that you have the right
to spend your clothing allotment
on gender-appropriate items
of clothing.
And so they restricted
me to only be
allowed to buy boys' clothes.
And, of course, you
know, the definition
of what boys' clothes
are is arbitrary.
But I guess what they
deemed to be boys' clothes
was all I was allowed to buy.
So I ended up--
before the first day of school,
I had to buy a new wardrobe.
$200 worth of clothes with--
no, $280 something, actually,
of clothes with my own money
out of pocket.
And, of course, like it--
sometimes it sounds like--
it's probably sounds
to some people
like it's really
not that big a deal.
So they won't buy you
the clothes you want.
But it's that they won't
buy me clothes that they
would buy for another youth.
And they're doing it solely
based on my sex, what
I was assigned at birth.
CURREY COOK: Let me
pause you right there,
because I think we want to
leave some time for questions.
And then I just want to say that
this is when Savannah called
our help desk line because she
sort of knew, like, OK, this
is clearly not right.
You know?
I don't know what the law
says, but this is not OK.
And I think it really
puts a fine point on what
we're talking about here.
Like when you're in these
out-of-home care systems,
the state controls
your whole life,
including the clothes that
you wear, right, and can buy.
So they were basically--
[? LYDIA: ?] And
whether you're out.
CURREY COOK: And
Right?
So they were basically
saying, oh, by the way,
gender is not defined anywhere.
So we're just going to say
it's gender assigned at birth
and deny a young person the
clothing that not only they
want as a baseline, right, but
also that actually helps affirm
their identity, which drops all
of these awful outcomes, right?
Suicidal ideation, depression,
and all this stuff.
And child welfare
agencies have to legally
make sure you're safe,
they are responsible
for your well-being, and
are going against everything
that any professional standard
says about how you're supposed
to respond to LGBT youth.
So I think, you know, Lydia
and Savannah's examples
really show, you know,
what a long way we
have to go in these systems
to affirm trans youth
and how they really bear the
brunt of all these things,
right?
And the good news,
though, is that Savannah
was affirmed in a school,
right, in rural Pennsylvania.
And I think that's a good
takeaway with the Supreme
Court kicking the
Gavin Grimm case back
down to the 4th Circuit
court of appeals.
It still may be a bit before we
get these issues to the Supreme
Court.
Could be a good thing,
may be a bad thing,
depending on the makeup
of the Supreme Court.
But in the meantime,
there are a lot
of schools that are
doing the right thing.
And I think hearing
their positive stories is
a good reminder to us
of the good stuff that's
going on out there, too.
So I'll turn it over
to Alex now and see
if anybody has questions.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX: The question was,
what is your interpretation
of the recent decision not
to hear the Gavin Grimm case?
What does it mean in
general for interpretation
that transgender people
are protected by sex
anti-discrimination laws?
CURREY COOK: So you all may have
followed that during the Obama
administration, the
Department of Justice
issued these guidelines to
the school district saying,
basically, Title IX, which
protects against discrimination
in schools based
on sex, that that
means you should
comply with the law,
affirm transgender
students at school.
And so the case that the
ACLU had with Gavin Grimm
sort of wound up
through the courts
and then the appellate
court basically
decided on that guidance.
And so then, as the Supreme
Court was considering
what to do with it, and it was
scheduled for oral argument,
the Trump administration
rescinded that guidance
and basically said, states, do
what you want, whatever, right?
Don't bully
transgender students.
But oh, by the way,
you don't actually
have to affirm their identity.
Which, of course, you can't
have both of those things
at the same time.
But the Supreme Court
then said, all right,
well, we're actually just
going to-- if this was based
on the guidance and the Trump
administration pulled it,
we're just going to
kick this back down
to the appellate
court to decide it.
And that's kind of
where it is now.
So they're going to
be deciding again.
That could result in a
really good decision,
as most courts
have said Title IX,
the sex protection means
you can't discriminate
based on gender identity.
But obviously we're
worried about who's
going to be on
the Supreme Court.
And so if another
justice or two drops off
and we have a
conservative majority,
that could be really
bad for a decision
like that one going back up.
ALEX: I wanted to ask
Soul specifically,
with kind of the new
administration and this focus
on immigration-- this is such
an issue we were hearing about
constantly throughout
the campaign--
and with this kind
of refugee ban
that's happened, how has
that affected you personally?
I know there's
legal implications.
But do you think
that there's ways
that it's affected you
beyond that as well?
SOUL: Yeah.
So, basically, I feel a
little bit sad about it
because I'm an
immigrant, of course.
I'm not a citizen.
And at the same time,
I'm just going to like--
I'm not going to talk about
like only how this affect me
as a LGBT, but as
a person, you know?
Because we know here
in the United States
there is a lot of
immigrant people, you know?
So, basically, if
we see, for example,
like if you take an example
of, well, Google, for example,
here.
How many immigrant people
work for Google, you know?
Or Facebook, or other
companies, you know?
I think the United States
is a free country, you know?
Is American and other people,
too, contribute to the economy,
you know, and stuff, you know.
And as we see, if
we have to kick out
all the immigrant
people, it's going
to be bad for immigrant
people first and also
for American people, too.
Because we all contribute
to develop America
and we all contribute to make
America great, as people say,
you know?
You know?
And yeah.
I feel bad about it, and I think
it's something we cannot let
happen, you know.
And that's how I feel
about it, you know.
And I want to say
also it affects me
as LGBT because if I
have to leave here,
where I'm going to go?
Not back in my country.
If I go back in
my country, how--
I don't know what
going to happen to me.
I got nowhere else
to go, you know.
Like, I got no family, I got
no place to stay, you know?
And as what I want to
add, too, is people,
when they heard about Africa,
they don't see really,
like, African people, too,
they have a LGBT community
over there, they did have too.
It's not like here.
People are like,
if you see like--
if you compare America to
Africa, it's like this kind.
Like you have a big difference
between them, you know?
And as I say it, in Africa,
we don't have LGBT--
we don't have LGBT Center.
We don't have LGBT community.
We don't have organizations who
work for LGBT people, you know?
We don't have an
organization [INAUDIBLE].
If LGBT people,
they have a problem
or you have like discrimination
or something, where
you going to go to [INAUDIBLE],
to claim your right, you know?
There's no rights for
LGBT people in Africa,
in some countries in Africa.
And we have to be aware of that.
And that's why I like
all the time, when
I decide to go to speak
and to share my story,
I just want to mention that
for people to be aware of that.
Like, it's not only
about, like, America here.
LGBT people, they-- yeah.
Here we have discrimination
and stuff, yeah.
But in Africa, too, we have it.
In Africa, like, people over
there, too, we need help, too.
LGBT community is
a LGBT community.
Like, African LGBT community,
American LGBT community,
doesn't matter, you know?
We all LGBT community.
And I think we have to think
about them, too, you know?
Yeah.
That's everything I have to say.
CURREY COOK: And then I
think Alex was saying to you,
wondering what we can do.
I mean, I think one
thing is making sure
that when we're
talking about refugees
or unaccompanied
children that come
is that there are obviously a
lot of those folks who identify
across the LGBT spectrum.
And so being sent
back to your country
would be horrific for
a variety of reasons.
But particularly for LGBT
people, as Soul was describing,
it's a whole other thing, right?
So speaking up about
that, that the stakes
are so high for
some of these people
going back to countries where
they may be killed, right?
Or just being who
they are is illegal.
AUDIENCE: So the
recent executive order
is pretty clear on its policy
towards refugee resettlement
for the next 120 days.
It's not super clear on its
treatment of current asylum
seekers, those with pending
cases in the United States.
And just on the topic of
international LGBT folks
who have actually made
it to the United States,
but not as refugees whose
cases are currently pending,
given your legal
expertise, what is
your knowledge of the likelihood
of those cases being processed
at all?
Or what can those folks expect?
CURREY COOK: Yeah.
I mean, first of all,
I think that we all
know there's like
a huge backlog,
generally, in
immigration courts.
Like another client of
mine who's from Ghana,
he just literally just missed--
you know, fled for his life,
just missed being killed.
A friend of his was
murdered who was gay.
And managed to get out all
the way through Latin America,
declared asylum at
the Mexican border,
was placed in detention
for seven months,
and ended up being released to
a family friend in the Bronx.
But his asylum case, the hearing
is set for November 2019.
This was like a year ago, right?
So in the meantime, he was
just sort of here in limbo.
We helped him get Special
Immigrant Juvenile Status, too,
because that's actually
something he was eligible for,
right?
So just in general,
it's just a mess.
A long time to wait.
And I think now,
particularly for people
who are in the
administrative process--
so they aren't in deportation
proceedings but they are
actually going to be going in
front of asylum officers who
have an unbelievable amount of
discretion in terms of whether
they grant asylum or don't--
that's one area
that really worries
me of what the direction
that's going to flow down
through the federal agency is
going to be about screening out
more and more people, which
is already just a really
subjective process.
But we know that we're having
this sort of word on high,
like, find more people, do
more raids, deport more people,
limit the number of
children that are coming in,
all of these things
that cut out people.
So I'm really
concerned that that's
going to play in there in
that administrative process.
In the court system, at least
you've got kind of levels,
right, of a judicial
officer and other folks
that are overseeing some cases.
So, in theory, anyway, there
should be some more protections
there.
ALEX: You know, we're talking
about things we can do.
And there are these sort of
organizational institutional
things we could do, like
supporting organizations
like Lambda.
On a kind of more
daily basis, I know
one issue I've seen kind
of on our listservs here
that comes up,
every now and then,
we'll see a parent of a
trans youth come on and say,
you know, I need some advice on
how to handle this situation,
and what advice
would you give me?
So I guess I'm curious for you
guys, as you were growing up,
you know, what were things that
were really helpful for you
that people did or said?
What were things that were
kind of negative for you that--
basically, how can we
as people be better
to support trans youth
as they're growing up?
SAVANNAH: I'm trying to
think how I want to say this.
Actually, Lydia, do you have
anything you want to say?
You can go first.
If not, I can.
LYDIA: Yeah.
I got a little something.
I'll try.
OK.
So as I was growing up,
really, on both the sides
of my family, my dad's side and
my mom's side, I'm the only--
literally the only, that we know
of, the only openly homosexual.
I'm the only--
I'm the LGBT and
the Q of the family.
Just that one.
But while I was growing up, I
never really actually came out.
It just happened.
And they found out, so I--
I guess my mom and
my sister had just--
well, my sister, she
then knew, I guess.
She just knew this whole time.
Didn't inform me that she knew.
My mom, it was kind of a
different thing with her.
It was like, I guess,
she found out someway.
I'm not sure how,
but she found out.
It took them a while to
really be OK with it.
But then they were like, oh, OK.
All right.
Sure.
But my best advice for
that is if you see signs--
like, I don't really know
what the signs could be,
but if you see signs of
anything, just, like,
don't ask them about it.
Just see, I guess, like, try
to talk to them about anything
in general, like
[INAUDIBLE] that you're not
sure of from your
child, or whatever.
Just talk to them about it.
Because I'm pretty sure
sometimes they want to tell you
but they're not sure
how you would take it.
Have an open mind.
A clear mindset.
And enter it without hostility.
Just go in with--
just go into the
conversation without--
what's the word for it?
I guess without violence.
And don't try to
force it out of them.
Don't try to force
it out of them.
Because if they're already--
they're more than likely having
a hard time telling you, just--
when they feel it's time
for them to tell you,
just let them tell you.
Don't be harsh about it.
Of course, you know,
if they don't like it,
they won't like it.
But still be supporting--
just be there for them in
any way, shape or form.
Because it will make--
trust me, it will make that
young boy or young girl,
whichever one, it will make
them feel a whole lot better.
CURREY COOK: I think--
I just wanted to say one
thing that I think we really
need to make sure and not
forget is that many of you
may have been
following in the news
recently this
epidemic particularly
against trans women of
color just being killed
at alarming rates, right?
Two trans women were just
killed in New Orleans
just in the course of
the last week or two.
Right?
And so all of this that
we're talking about, right,
the assault on trans
people, on LGBT people,
in general by this
administration,
by state legislatures like
Texas and other places,
lack of protections
in the law, it's
all part and parcel of
the same thing, right?
Giving a message that
these people are other.
Right?
And that absolutely
contributes to violence
against that population.
So thinking about Casey and--
I'm sorry, Savannah
and Lydia and Soul
navigating the world, right, and
having these negative messages
also contributes to suicidal
ideation, depression,
and stuff.
So sometimes we can
distance through the law
and the government
and these actions
from what's really
happening to people
and the violence
they experience.
But it's actually all the same.
So as we go forward and
advocating and fighting
against this, I think it's
important to keep that
at the front of our minds.
And I want to just
say a huge thank you
to Lydia and Savannah and
Soul for sharing all of this.
ALEX: Yeah.
Thank you guys all
so much for sharing.
Really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]